if you're 45 and have tried to make
relationships with women work and failed
I can understand you saying that you're
going mgtow and that you're casting out
relationships because you've been hurt
too many times if you're 19 and you've
had your heart broken for the first time
how the you saying you're going
your own way like what is that that's
you just giving up everybody's got
challenges everybody's got things that
they're struggling with man up the world
is as easy and convenient as it's ever
going to be and you're complaining about
the fact that all the existential weight
of living everybody's got that everybody
has to face this stuff I don't think
there's enough people saying man up yeah
and I don't mean ignore your emotions I
mean integrate your emotions talk about
them Manning up also includes being
mature about your emotions it means
crying in front of your friends and
being vulnerable and open this isn't
like some ancient archetype of
patriarchal toxic masculinity this is me
saying transcend and include your
masculinity transcend and include the
challenges that you've been through